مقاطع الفيديو التي نشرتها على تطبيق
تيليجرام اداره خرسون العسكريه الاقليميه
تظهر حجم الدمار الذي لحق بعده منازل بسبب
اعمال قصف استهدفت منطقه خرسون جنوب
اوكرانيا وذلك بعد هجوم روسي نفذ الثلاثاء
ليلا السلطات المحليه قالت ان القوات
الروسيه اطلقت على خرسون اكثر من 500
قذيفه مدفعيه وشنت 7 غارات جويه ياتي هذا
فيما تعهد الرئيس الاوكراني
بالاستمرار في الهجوم المضاد واستعاده
السيطره على مصادر الطاقه النوويه
سنحرص على ضمان التحرير الكامل لمحطه
زابوريشيا النوويه من المحتلين الروس
وسنحمي اوكرانيا وكامل اوروبا من الابتزاز
النووي الروسي
الحرب في اوكرانيا اضحت مكلفه بالنسبه
لروسيا الكرملين اعلن عن زياده كبيره في
ميزانيه الدفاع مؤكدا استعداد موسكو لما
وصف بالحرب الطويله والهجينه في اوكرانيا
مع اقتراب فصل الشتاء وزاره الماليه
الروسيه قالت ان النفقات الدفاع سترتفع
بنسبه 70% تقريبا خلال عام 2024 منذ
اندلاع النزاع العام الماضي عززت روسيا
تصنيع الاسلحه والذخائر والقدرات
الصاروخيه واللوجستيه وتامين موارد الطاقه
النوويه وضخت اموالا طائله في الاتها
العسكريه رغم ارتفاع التضخم وضعف العمله
الروسيه